we have had on this program from a
number of businesses or time and time
again that clarity is what is needed
both ours to transition period and to
where were ultimately going to get end
up why is that and what do you think of
what you've heard so far well there's an
absolute lack of clarity and as you say
that's probably the single most damaging
thing to business business would rather
get a straight negative answer early so
then it can make plans then not know
where we're heading which as a country
we simply do not I think really the
government's strategy seems to be let's
wait and see what corner we get painted
into and then say that's the answer
business can't operate like that we need
to know at least 1 2 years in advance if
you want to build a factory to employ
people you need to know am I going to be
cited here I'm gonna be cited in Europe
so we need clarity of the situation but
of course they can't give clarity of the
situation because the government is so
divided about the kind of bricks that it
wants the one thing that's consistent is
the voice of entrepreneurship in this
country 97% of entrepreneurs don't want
to leave they think it's a bad idea to
leave but they're very clear that if if
we have to leave let's make sure the
deal is agreed before we actually step
through that door because if we step
through that door without having agreed
a deal
we then throw away any negotiation
position we have seen the government
doesn't seem to really understand that
position but I mean are you not in any
way concerned about the fact that we've
heard this week from Michele Barney do
you know what transition period it's not
a given not at all in fact I don't
really see the point in a transition
period the whole point of article 50 was
that that was the transition you know
when people voted for brexit and they
thought long and hard you know it wasn't
as binary as the media's making out at
the moment a lot of people that I know
most people I think most people sort of
felt there were pluses of leaving and
pluses of stay and they did think long
and hard and they voted to leave and
when they voted to leave they didn't
vote for a deal nobody talks about soft
brexit or hard brexit it was either what
a mistake though perhaps there should
have been greater discussion in the
business community and more broadly
about the potential outcomes not at all
I think people just felt they wasn't
working for Britain you know it really
isn't working for people and that's why
they wanted to leave and if it was such
a great you know if there
was such a great club we wouldn't want
to leave that you wouldn't be
threatening us - you know - if we do
leave they're running it more like a
protection racket trying to do what they
can to scare us and that's really not
something we you know we want to be part
of it's just not working for people in
Britain anymore at the very least which
you can understand why there are people
out there who look at the rhetoric
emerging from Brussels and agree with
Lance that there is a punitive element
to the way in which we're being dealt
with by the European Union at the moment
no I'd totally disagree I mean if you
look at what they actually say that
they're bending over backwards to say
that there's no punishment here they
just keep reminding us very politely
that it was us that chose to leave so we
need to say what it is that we want
angela merkel's you're saying look tell
me what you want and then we can help
you get there but Britain is like no you
tell us like they're just saying quite
easily you decided to leave and by the
way when it came to the brexit decision
I negotiated most of the people on the
other side they were absolutely
equivocal of course we will stay and
have unfettered access to the single
market of course we're not going to be
leaving the customs union in the same
way that said of course that'd be 350
million pounds getting to the NHS the
brexit that this country was promised is
not the brexit that's being delivered
it's absolutely a different bill of
goods and I think as just pragmatic
Patriots we have to be able to clear
sight to take a look at the deal that
they finally do negotiate and say it's
that good for this country or not if
it's good for this country I'll be the
first one to advocate for it if it's not
good for this country if it's actually
going to damage this country and I'll be
saying we've reserve the right to change
our minds at least have a rethink
disagree with you or Richard you know
which way well the EU works for big
business but most people in Britain are
employed by small businesses and its
small businesses that suffered over the
years all the regulations day after day
sort of new regulations that keep coming
through that that make it very difficult
them big businesses are bureaucracies
themselves they lobby the EU to put in
rule to protect their businesses which
stops small disruptive businesses coming
through and it's you know small
businesses employ
more people in the UK then big business
stars and as I said this bricks it was
about the little man
about the little man standing up to this
in a crow Gnaeus corporate world and
this sort of bureaucratic world and
saying look we've had enough there's a
different way most countries in the
world don't have a trade deal with the
EU we don't need a trade deal with the
EU to trade our biggest trading partner
in the world is the USA we don't have a
trade deal with them yet we still trade
so it's you know you don't need a trade
deal to trade this is one of the things
it's awkward and you're sort of having a
debate with someone from the vote leave
side day is night and night is day
they're putting that the EU is there for
big business the eve those to protect
the common man at its heart it is
protect humans and societies communities
against the ravages of international
capitalism but it's also people that
paid for brexit are a billionaire elite
the absol whole principle of brexit is
to bring together a continent so it can
trade and be peaceful be positives which
really would you at least accept that
the dessous do scientists the economists
actually they're saying that there will
be a negative impact directly as a
result of a heart brexit that they could
well be wrong and that actually in the
medium to long term the freeing of
ourselves from the regulatory
environment imposed upon us by the
european union might well give us the
opportunity to get the economy back on
track in a way in which we haven't been
able to since the banks went went done i
don't know when 99% of the world
economists say it's gonna have a
negative effect on the economy i tend to
side with them there's 1% that say no
it's going to be good but 99% it's like
climate change scientists 99 percent of
them say climate change is real I'm
gonna go with them so where reality is
your confidence come my confidence comes
from my own experience and I'll I
disagree on the point about
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs welcome
change change provides opportunity in
every day in our lives change is
happening but it's small incremental
change and we don't notice it's like
you're on this treadmill and it's only
after 20 years or 30 40 years you look
back you think oh my goodness how on
earth did I get into the European Union
is not small increment no but that's the
beauty that's the beauty of it it it is
a massive change its throws us off that
treadmill that allows us to step back
and say we're in a whole new world here
how can we seize the good
stuff shed the bad stuff and I think
that this is the greatest opportunity
for Britain in a generation and we
should seize it really positive so far
this opportunity in inverted commas that
we've chosen has meant that we've gone
from being the best performing economy
in the g7 to the worst performing
economy in the g7 it's seen our wages go
down in real terms the nurses have
started leaving young people feel that
they've had their futures taken and 97%
of entrepreneurs of small businesses
that want to stay in 97% it was a fact